what's your general sense of like the
bitcoin perspective on like never
changing uh and kind of remaining rigid
and whatever happens happens but the
chain stays the chain versus some of
these other approaches like around the
dow hack and the hard fork like do you
think that it's important
uh that bitcoin has stayed rigid or are
there times where it would have been
beneficial to have actually pursued a
similar strategy
yeah i mean i think that's just the
difference between bitcoin and a lot of
the the crypto ecosystem and that's okay
uh you know bitcoin has just this
immutable uh chain of property rights
and you know it's gonna tick-tock next
block you can't do anything about it a
block will be mined you know in the next
10 minutes or whenever it does and no
one in anywhere in the world can do
anything to stop that um whereas like
you know with ethereum or solana like
you know there's there's times where the
chain stops all together because they
need to fix something that's okay uh
just it's just you know that when you're
talking about money uh global like
decentralized money for the world to use
versus you know a smart contracts chain
or platform uh you know there's
obviously a lot of differences there and
that's okay i mean that's that's where
the debate comes in but when you try to
compare the two or claim something is
ultrasound money or uh you know that
they're even competing at all um even
though you know because of the crypto
market liquidity a lot of times when
bitcoin's up a lot of altcoins chains
are also that the ticker symbol is up or
when bitcoin's down the whole market's
down i think it's just you know the
conversation or the debate i guess if
you want to call it uh should just be
shifted entirely because they're not
really competing for the same market
despite what a lot of people think
yeah i think that's a very uh very fair
way to look at it uh let's get into some
of the charts that you've got for us
today you've got the usdc and usdt
circulating supply so
this is circles stablecoin and then
tether
the numbers just keep going up into the
right man it's pretty impressive to see
how fast this stuff's growing wh why is
this important
yeah so the past couple weeks we talked
about you know equity market
correlations we looked at on-chain stuff
we looked at derivative stuff
so today i thought i'd just throw
together some stuff about kind of the
stablecoin market and and how that's
blossoming um just to cover something a
little bit different but you know an
important part of this entire ecosystem
so uh you know circle tether uh the two
leading stablecoin issuers we see
rumblings of
uh cbdc talks whether that's congress or
the you know fed governor saying hey we
need a central bank digital currency
we're seeing what's happening in canada
with that you know aggressive overreach
by government on people's uh bank
accounts and financial services so all
this stuff is going to be uh you know
heavily debated over the coming years
and so
um you know do you want to hold
something like a stable coin that can be
you know uh like choke point by uh some
some central issue or i think a lot of
people are gonna come to realize that
their money isn't actually their money
so stable coins um they're actually
serving a pretty big purpose in in the
world in like in this ecosystem and no
it's not uh immutable decentralized
money like say bitcoin is that's
censorship resistant seizure resistant
but what it does do is it allows dollars
to kind of flow freely on crypto rails
so this next chart the circulating
supply here is about 120 billion year
over year the growth is like 200 percent
it was about four it was about 40
billion dollars combined uh a year ago
today and so
um over the last year these two uh
stable coins have done like two trillion
dollars of transfer volume each which is
like you know
like an order of magnitude a couple
orders of magnitude more than their
actual market cap so that they're
actually like the the circulation rate
or how fast these things are changing
hands is actually remarkable uh when
you're thinking about this versus say
dollars in the banking system um and so
you know for the longest time the crypto
market didn't even have any stable coins
it's just like bitcoin was your was your
kind of your safe haven and when the
when these kind of local bubbles pop you
had nowhere to really run and the on and
off ramps are really really tricky to
use um so now people and you can debate
you know how safe uh some stable coins
are or if their reserves are backed or
not and that's an entirely different
discussion but a lot of these stable
coins and i think you know increasingly
so will just hold treasuries and
essentially they're just like
you know us dollars treasuries uh that
can be changed hands in crypto markets
and you know a couple seconds around the
world and so uh in terms of innovation
uh i don't know i don't know how it's
just you know another kind of database
entry on a you know centralized ledger
and that's fine but it's a lot better
than you know say the the legacy banking
system and integration with the crypto
markets today so when you look at uh the
stable coin like uh we looked at both
the circulating supply and the annual
transfer volume uh is it your thought
process that just more and more the
financial system is going to move over
because these are superior rails to
other dollar rails uh and people who
want that stable value as long as they
can get comfortable with any perceived
or real risks of what's backing it
auditing it etc once they get
comfortable with that just the entire
financial system will flow over into
stables
yeah so i mean how i think about it is
and i focus on on bitcoin you know with
almost all my time because i think it
fixes or addresses one of the biggest
problems in the world today there's a
300 400 trillion dollar problem and
we've talked about that it's a broken
cost of capital right so if you have
money in the bank account you deposit
with a bank they actually lend your
money out for you fractionally they
fractionally reserve your deposit and
lend it out to other uh debtors
but you don't get any of that yield you
don't get any of that upside even though
uh they're lending it out on your behalf
um so so that zero percent yield you get
in a seven percent inflationary
environment uh you know you're not doing
too well but with say stable coins are
in this kind of
emerging crypto bitcoin ecosystem what
you can do is you can actually lend
peer-to-peer so say on ftx centralized
you know
exchange you can lend your dollars to
someone else that's using margin or you
know let's say a d5 protocol right
you're putting you're putting stable
coins into a liquidity pool and right
there's there's a debate about you know
what's the custodial risk what's the uh
the platform risk on a lot of these
protocols um is you know are they gonna
get hacked are there exploits and that's
something that people are finding out in
real time like it's not risk-free in the
sense that you know nobody there's not
the fdic gonna back you if you get
hacked right but what you can do is you
can lend your stables out or you can
borrow dollars
at a at a really a market rate right so
sometimes that market rate in this
ecosystem is five percent sometimes it's
20 but these markets are free and open
and these stable coins allow basically
you know creditors debtors people that
want to collateralize their assets and
borrow or
lend to someone else to do that at a
rate that's decided by the market and
not 12 guys sitting in a room saying the
fed's fund rate is going to be zero
percent again and so i think that's the
exciting thing about what's happening
with you know kind of dollars on crypto
rails yeah it's wild that there's 12
people who make that decision but that
is the world that we live in today hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time